bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette dernière
édition de l'année 2012 réalisée en
direct à 18h du 7 8 des la semaine
prochaine une série de rendez-vous vous
sera proposé pour revenir sur l'effet
marquants de l'année 2012 mais aussi sur
les événements principaux de 2013 en
attendant en ce 20 décembre il sera
question de Port-Royal Deschamps qui
ouvre son centre de ressources pour qui
et pourquoi les explications de son
directeur qui est avec nous sur ce
plateau ce sera dans un instant bonsoir
Alice comme chaque jeudi la chronique de
l'Echo dans une vingtaine de minutes ce
soir on recevra l'association initiative
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui accorde
des prêts aux entreprises et qui
s'associent à scientipole pour cibler
les entreprises innovantes nous recevons
le président de cette association dans
une quinzaine de minutes parlons
également de la stratégie de McDonald's
France puisque vous avez rencontré le
PDG l'entreprise qui est installé à
Guyancourt la chronique de l'Echo vers
18h20 si vous nous suivez en direct les
autres sujets qui seront développés ce
soir en images à présent un nouveau
président pour l'opivoal office public
de HLM rom
à quelques jours de la fin d'année le
bilan de la cité sécurité routière était
dressée les chiffres des 11 premiers
mois de l'année sont bons le nombre
d'accidents étant recul de 9% et le
nombre de blessés de 7% seul le nombre
de tués progresse au déplore 46 décès
sur les routes des Yvelines et depuis le
début de l'année en cause la vitesse
l'inattention l'alcoolémie pour ces
fêtes de fin d'année une programmation
soutenu de contrôle routier sera
effectué dans les zones accidentogènes
plus de 50 contrôles quotidiens dans le
département par ailleurs des contrôles
d'éthylotest seront effectués dans les
établissements ouverts entre deux heures
et 7 heures du matin
l'opivoa a donc un nouveau président ces
dernières semaines ont été marquées par
les tensions et par les démissions
également reportages d'Anthony rech et
de Guillaume camps et puis juste après
nous partirons pour Port-Royal des
Champs
romain Colas est le nouvel homme fort de
l'opivoie après plusieurs semaines de
crise interne et de non-gouvernance le
conseil d'administration a élu l'actuel
deuxième vice-président de l'Office lors
de la réunion du 17 décembre à 33 ans
romain Colas remplace le président des
missionnaires Michel Viallet mais le
maire de Boussy-Saint-Antoine l'affirme
il n'occupe ce poste que pour assurer
une transition et redonner de la
crédibilité à cet office public il
fallait assurer la continuité de
l'opivoie avec notamment le vote du
budget 2013 approuvé à l'unanimité ce 17
décembre cette crise politique n'a pas
eu de répercussion sur les locataires
dès les premiers jours de janvier une
nouvelle réunion est prévue avec les
présidents de Conseils Généraux le
travail quotidien de l'opivoine n'a pas
été perturbé et surtout c'est signatures
ses engagements ont pu être honoré mais
il était nécessaire que nous délibérions
hier soir pour assurer cette cette
continuité et avec une mission claire
qui m'a été assignée par le conseil
d'administration c'est de remettre tout
le monde autour de la table d'appeler
les uns et les autres à la raison pour
que nous puissions trouver les les voies
et moyens d'une gouvernement stable
pérenne
un centre de ressources documentaire et
d'interprétation vient d'ouvrir donc au
musée Port-Royal Deschamps à
Magny-les-Hameaux bonsoir Philippe Cluet
vous en êtes le directeur ce centre de
ressources documentaire centre
d'interprétation du patrimoine mais
aussi lieu de rencontre d'animation et
d'échanges il servira à qui et à quoi
il veut servir j'espère au plus grand
nombre possible de toute façon nos
établissements sont ouverts au plus
large public effectivement à la base le
projet c'est d'abord un endroit où l'on
peut trouver de l'information sur
Port-Royal et le projet de départ était
de créer un centre
de recherche et de ressources autour des
grands thèmes de Port-Royal c'est vrai
que ce projet également a évolué
peut-être simplement parce que dans nos
musées
les visiteurs le savent peu mais il y a
des bibliothèques généralement certains
musées ont des bibliothèques qui sont
assez largement ouvertes
c'est sans doute pas l'habitude on va au
musée où on va travailler sur des livres
l'idée c'est que on peut peut-être
trouver une autre façon d'aborder nos
musées nos sites et nos lieux de
patrimoine avec la visite classique d'un
musée avec des médiations particulières
donc des visites des conférences des
ateliers pour les enfants et puis la
possibilité aussi de venir se poser et
venir lire donc l'idée c'est d'amener le
public à venir lire après une visite on
va dire plus classique de ensuite se
découvrir ce centre absolument l'idée
effectivement double aussi bien
recherche que ouvert au public qui
aurait envie d'en savoir plus donc pour
les chercheurs j'imagine que vous pensez
aussi aux étudiants de l'université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
bien entendu forcément d'abord à eux
effectivement et puis peut-être plus
large bien entendu puisque nos thèmes
m'intéressent des étudiants j'allais
dire du monde entier ils se rendent déjà
dans le centre et il se rendent déjà
alors il se rend déjà il venait déjà au
musée ils vont se rendre bien sûr ils
vont continuer à venir au musée mais
dans le centre qui vient juste d'ouvrir
vous avez déjà beaucoup de retours
justement de
d'impression qui vous ont été livrés sur
l'ouverture il était attendu en tout cas
ce centre oui le centre était attendu
c'est un projet qui remonte à assez
longtemps c'est d'abord une proposition
de la communauté d'agglomération qui est
partenaire du musée et qui a proposé dès
2015 de créer une structure en lien avec
le musée qui permettrait cette ouverture
très large dans le cadre de la lecture
publique
très joli projet qui a évolué
en concertation avec le musée et la
communauté d'agglomération pour
justement imaginer cet endroit où
d'abord c'est le premier retour qu'on a
on a envie de se poser on est bien c'est
assez chaleureux le le
l'endroit de donne envie de se poser on
va s'y rendre justement on va aller voir
comment ça se déroule sur place quel est
le cadre que vous avez accordé à ce
centre reportage pour la rédaction
Johanna Soudry et Guillaume camps
pensez depuis plusieurs années le centre
de ressources et d'interprétation de
Port-Royal voit enfin le jour un lieu
paisible au cœur du site de Port-Royal
Deschamps comme une invitation au livre
d'abord on s'adresse aux fréquentants du
musée aux personnes qui viennent visiter
le lieu c'est à part l'objectif on vient
accompagner répondre à des intérêts de
lecture
en début ou en fin de visite sur ça peut
être sur Champaigne ça peut être sur
peut-être la prochaine exposition resto
qui se prépare dans le salon de lecture
3000 volumes sont consultables sur place
parmi les thématiques abordées le
jansénisme et plus largement l'histoire
de France et le 17e siècle quand a
Blaise Pascal et Jean Racine figurentes
de Port-Royal leurs ouvrages occupent
une place privilégiée si le centre de
ressources se tourne principalement vers
les chercheurs il compte beaucoup sur
les étudiants de l'université de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines le Sanders
source on y accès avec l'entrée parc et
on va on a créé une carte de lecteur une
liste de lecteurs qui permet d'avoir un
accès libre ensuite
facilité forcément à partir d'une
régularité de fréquentation
à chaque saison des visites thématiques
sont proposées au public pour échanger
sur l'histoire de Port-Royal prochain
rendez-vous hivernal samedi 12 janvier
autour des artisans de l'histoire
et puisque Johanna le mentionnait ce
rendez-vous hivernal le 12 janvier
samedi autour des artisans de l'histoire
comment il va se dérouler ce rendez-vous
on en a déjà eu un c'est dire cette ce
sont des ateliers avec des professeurs
de l'Université de Saint-Quentin et des
membres du musée et qui monte aux
personnes qui s'inscrivent un petit peu
mais comment est-ce qu'on fabrique cette
ces histoires cette mémoire comment
est-ce qu'on travaille sur les métiers
de l'histoire et du patrimoine parce que
l'idée c'est pas uniquement de proposer
des documents c'est aussi d'avoir une
certaine interaction complémentarité des
animations tout un programme a été conçu
construit autour du centre oui autour du
centre et autour du musée bien entendu
parce que l'idée c'est que le centre est
aussi l'instrument qui nous permet
d'aller plus loin qu'une simple visite
auprès de nos publics et c'est sur le
centre que va aussi s'articuler un
programme qui existe déjà de conférence
comme faisait déjà et l'idée c'est que
c'est une façon vraiment complète
complètement différente ou
complémentaire de d'aborder d'aborder la
visite de Port-Royal quels sont les
rendez-vous les principaux rendez-vous
peut-être qui vont des se dérouler
durant cette année 2013 alors plusieurs
rendez-vous où on a alors un cycle de
conférence assez régulier et souvent qui
s'appuie sur les événements du musée une
exposition de dessins de 18e siècle
autour de Jean Restout on aura donc des
conférences sur l'artiste et pourquoi
est-ce qu'il a travaillé pour Port-Royal
une rencontre aussi sur l'évolution des
savoirs avec une table ronde organisée
avec les responsables de Wikipédia parce
que le livre au 17e est un vecteur de
savoir Wikipédia internet emmené un
autre après tout ces deux vecteurs
marchent de la même manière c'est aussi
une façon de montrer par le ce type de
manifestation que les grands thèmes de
Port-Royal restent des thèmes absolument
modernes et actuels c'est contemporain
vous voulez véritablement sortir ce
peut-être de cette image qui fait que on
parlera d'une époque très révolue très
ancienne et là on le voit bien c'est
moderne contemporain faire ce parallèle
avec Wikipédia par exemple les puristes
apprécient d'ailleurs parce que c'est
pas
osé par particulièrement ça peut être
osé mais je dirais que le patrimoine à
deux sens qu'à partir du moment où c'est
une question pour aujourd'hui le
patrimoine n'est pas une chose morte
c'est une façon de s'interroger sur la
façon dont nous vivons les thèmes de
Port-Royal sont des thèmes vivants
nous ne sommes pas à mon sens un lieu
qui serait inconsatoire d'une mémoire du
17e siècle qui n'intéresse personne
les grands thèmes de Port-Royal c'est
l'endroit où on a inventé la démocratie
parlementaire c'est l'endroit où on
invente la liberté de conscience les
questions que se posent les citoyens
français à l'époque de Louis XIV sont
les mêmes que celles que nous nous
posons aujourd'hui et sans doute le
centre d'interprétation est un des
moyens il n'est pas le seul pour le
musée de faire comprendre à nos
visiteurs et à notre public tous ces
thèmes qui sont autant de façons de
répondre à leurs questions à eux et ça
permet de rendre accessible aussi cette
culture oui d'éviter l'élitisme surtout
de la faire sortir de l'image un petit
peu froide qu'elle peut avoir parce que
c'est une culture qui à mon sens est
accessible il faut simplement trouver
les clés j'aimerais qu'on s'attarde sur
le fond dont vous disposez je vais
donner quelques chiffres et vous me
corrigez si je me trompe plus de 3000
ouvrages en accès libre le fond entier
c'est 13200 unités documentaires donc
6000 ouvrages imprimés anciens 5000
ouvrages de bibliographie moderne 1200
pièces d'archives ancienne du 17e au 19e
siècle et 1000 dossier documentaire
c'est assez conséquent absolument c'est
constitué ce fond alors c'est un fond
qui s'est constitué par étape
successives
une bibliothèque qui a été rassemblée
dès le 19e siècle par le propriétaire
qui habitait à Manille pendant toute
cette période
compléter avec des achats fait par
l'État depuis que le musée s'est
installé délègue de bibliothèque
importantes la bibliothèque d'un
philosophe suive important qui avait à
fond d'ouvrage considérable sur Pascal
un certain nombre de dossiers de
chercheurs qui ont fait donc de leur de
leur note de recherche marche au musée
et tout ça constitue un fond assez
unique en France sur les questions de
Port-Royal et il s'enrichit encore ce
fond il continue à s'enrichir c'est ça
qui fait que ce fond est vivant vous
avez des acquisitions récentes ce soir
on a quelques acquisitions récentes
alors dans les collections du musée de
dessin qui seront présentés à
l'exposition de printemps le manuscrit
d'une vie de Saint-Louis écrite à
Port-Royal à la fin du 17e siècle et un
certain nombre de thèses récentes
récemment publié on parle donc ce soir
de ce centre de ressources de Port-Royal
Deschamps on va en revoir quelques
images après le reportage qui nous a
entraîné là-bas fait visiter les lieux
là on peut peut-être s'intéresser
justement à ce lieu à ce cadre vous avez
véritablement voulu que ce soit un havre
dédié à la littérature
vous avez mis en place comment justement
toute la l'architecture la mise en scène
pour le public qui viendra se rendre à
ce centre de ressources c'est un travail
partagé parce que on l'a fait aussi avec
l'aide des équipes de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et je crois et
c'est là-dessus qu'on est tombé d'accord
que c'était
important de souligner cette impression
de de confort de bien-être pour pouvoir
travailler parce qu'après tout c'est
dans cette atmosphère là que au XVIIe
siècle les gens qui nous ont précédés
ont travaillé écrit écrire réfléchis et
on garde cette atmosphère un petit peu
intacte aujourd'hui pour les chercheurs
les étudiants et nos visiteurs qui
voudront venir en savoir un peu plus sur
nous et donc c'est à Mani les hameau les
coordonnées qui se sont affichées filées
plus restés encore avec nous quelques
instants est-ce que vous connaissez
Harry non pas du tout Harry Potter
régulation intelligence c'est le système
novateur qui équipe l'appartement de
David hein jeune trader mais c'est
surtout le nom du court-métrage de deux
amis versaillais ils sont avec nous tout
à l'heure sur ce plateau voici déjà la
bande-annonce pour vous faire patienter
impossible il reste 4 firewall avant
intrusion dans le système
et je suis presque
trois firewall Franck ils vont vous
identifier
a découvert tout à l'heure dans le 7 8
et d'ailleurs l'intégralité de ce
court-métrage sera diffusé à partir de
ce weekend sur notre antenne je vous
donnerai les principaux horaires d'ici
la fin de cette édition merci Philippe
et donc d'être venu nous parler de ce
centre de ressources de Port-Royal pour
s'y rendre les coordonnées les
informations pratiques s'affiche à
nouveau sur votre écran une petite
précision le coup pour y accéder 1 euro
c'est la première fois qu'on s'y rend et
une fois qu'on a sa carte de lecteur
l'accès au centre et libre voilà encore
un bon argument pour vous y rendre merci
donc à vous la chronique de l'écho à
suivre avec Alice Gastine auparavant des
élèves de 5e du collège des sauts à
Guyancourt se sont vu remettre des
instruments de musique deux heures de
cours supplémentaires par semaine pour
apprendre un nouvel instrument Anthony
Rech et Elodie moine nous explique les
détails de cette opération
ces élèves de la classe orchestre du
collège des saules de Guyancourt
viennent de recevoir leurs instruments
c'est leur tout premier cours et pour
l'instant ces apprentis musiciennes
essaient de faire connaissance avec leur
flux de traversière
c'est le petit doigt en fait ça fait
très mal
quand on souffle dans la fuite ça fait
pas forcément un bruit il faut bien
souffler dans le trou
la classe orchestre s'effectue sur trois
années scolaires jusqu'en classe de 3e
les élèves du collège des saules suivent
deux heures de cours par semaine la
première en atelier pratique la seconde
en tutti le moment où toutes les
familles d'instruments violents guitare
basse percussion et flûte se rassemblent
pour former l’orchestre le plaisir de
jouer reste le maître mot car les
collégiens ne sont pas notés par leur
professeur
dans un premier temps avoir un joli son
et puis maîtriser donc la pose des
doigts sur chaque clé voilà ce qui va
demander un petit certain temps qui
s'ajoutait un petit peu les partitions
quelques rythmes mais le but est
vraiment de jouer ensemble
c'est 20 apprentis musiciens devront
être prêts pour leur première
représentation officielle à la fin de
l'année scolaire en attendant ils se
sont déjà produits sur scène en chanson
lors de la cérémonie de remise des
instruments